welcome back I will now introduce you to
it to the concept of well I've already
introduced what vectors are but
introduced you and how they can be even
more useful and we're going to use that
to actually solve two-dimensional
projectile motion problems so for the
now we can introduce a game where you
just don't throw the ball straight up
you can see how far you can throw the
ball or what's the optimal angle to
throw the ball at so hopefully you'll
find this even more fun if you can
imagine it then then the one-dimensional
projectile motion so everything we've
been doing so far
you know I think you you did hopefully
you have an intuition that the the
different unit of vector and a scalar is
that a vector has direction right so a
vector vector vector has let me do colon
instead has magnitude and Direction
magnitude and direction while speed
while while a scalar scalar has only
magnitude an example of a vector
you know velocity is a vector that's
easy you know they both start with V but
velocity is a vector R I well in those
examples we were doing before we said
that the ball was going was we said you
know sometimes we said that the final
velocity was minus 30 meters per second
and so where was the magnitude in what
was the direction well the magnitude was
30 right and the direction was I knew
what the direction was by the sine of
that minus sign and that same problem if
someone asked me what is the speed of
the ball right before it hits the ground
I'd have said oh the speed is just 30
meters per second and I wouldn't have to
say 30 meters per second down or minus
30 meters per second I just say 30
meters per second because that's its
speed I don't know what direction it's
going this speed so that's his speed and
in a general way and you probably in one
dimension you could say that the scalar
of the same quantity that the scalar
tends to be the absolute value
of the vector quantity right so because
in this example the speed is just the
absolute value of this alright if if my
initial velocity if my initial velocity
was plus that's not not equal that's
actually just equal if the initial
velocity was plus 30 meters per second
then the speed would still be 30 meters
per second so I just want to introduce
that notion and in in in one dimension
velocity can kind of be Direction can be
implied by positive or negative numbers
but now when we when we go into two
dimensions we're going to have to get a
little bit more sophisticated in terms
of how we how we give direction so let
me clear this so let me give an example
where I take a ball I take a green ball
clearly a green ball and I throw it I
throw this that's a straight line I
throw it at ten meters per second but I
don't throw it straight up I actually
throw it at a let me think of a good
angle i I throw it at a I don't know I
thought it at a 45 degree angle or if
you like radians that's what's that's pi
PI over four right so let's say I throw
it at a 45 degree angle so now that my
problem becomes a lot more complicated
how do one how do i how do i specify the
magnitude and direction and then how do
i solve this problem how do i figure out
how high it goes how far it goes etc etc
and hopefully that's what we will be
able to teach you over the course of the
next couple of videos this is the ground
right so one if I just want to give the
speed and direction or the magnitude and
the direction for this vector quantity I
have just specified I just you know I
could just say my velocity my velocity
or my initial velocity my initial
velocity is 10 meters per second at 45
degrees you know to the Hirai
in or something like that so that that
would be a legitimate velocity
specification but it's kind of hard to
deal with so what I'm going to teach you
something very neat about vectors is
that you can actually break up Vector
into its into I don't want to introduce
too complicated terms it but into its
orthogonal components so you can say
well something moving at 10 meters per
second at this angle is actually moving
at some speed upwards it's moving at
some speed upwards and it's moving at
some speed in this case to the right
let's say it in the positive direction
right so if you imagine this coordinate
axis it's moving in the Y direction at
some speed and it's moving moving in the
X direction at some speed and when
they're combined it's it's some way you
get this this this angle or you're
moving it at kind of an incline so let's
how do I figure out if I have 10 meters
per second and I'm moving how do I break
that down into my vertical speed and my
horizontal speed and I'll show you that
it's actually pretty cool it's it's it's
pretty straightforward you can what you
can do is you can actually draw a vector
where the length of the vector is its
magnitude so let's draw it again so
let's say this is a coordinate axis and
that the length of this line right here
is 10 the length of this line is 10 and
it represents you know speed or velocity
right at this point and we know this
angle is 45 degrees so it turns out that
the vertical component of this of the
balls velocity would be equivalent to
the length of this side and the
horizontal component would be equivalent
to the length of this side right and you
know this this arrow right here is the
same thing as this arrow I just
translated it to the right just so that
you see that it's just a it's just a
triangle and it's just not any triangle
it's a right triangle
because it and what's useful you know
you could you don't get too complicated
with linear algebra but it's important
that the two directions that you're
breaking it up in are well they don't
have to be but it makes it useful that
they are at right angles to each other
because then we can start to use a lot
of our trig ratios so let's let's just
figure out this problem I think you just
need to see a lot of examples so we're
going 10 meters per second in the four
at 45 degrees well what what speed am i
going straight up then what is the
straight up component of this 10 meters
per second well how do we figure out
this side if this was just a regular
triangle if if this is the hypotenuse
this is opposite and this is adjacent
right so let me break out some
trigonometry so gah
so and if you don't remember your
trigger you never learn tray guy I
encourage you to go watch the trig
videos that we have sohcahtoa so which
which of the of the trig ratios involve
the opposite and the hypotenuse opposite
and hypotenuse so or sine right and we
know that sine of theta sine of theta is
equal to opposite over hypotenuse so we
know that the sine of 45 degrees sine of
45 degrees is equal to let's let's just
call this my my my velocity a vertical
that's I've never seen that variable
used in actual physics classes but I
think it makes sense this is the
velocity vertical and this is the
velocity horizontal and later I'll
introduce more conventional conventions
but that will double do this for now so
my vertical velocity or the velocity
that I'm going straight up is is is
going to well sine of 45 degrees is my
vertical velocity over my just my kind
of angled velocity right this hypotenuse
over 10 and what's my horizontal
velocity and so if I were to solve for
vertical velocity I get vertical
velocity is equal to 10 times the sine
of 45 degrees
and then similarly my horizontal
velocity this is the adjacent over
hypotenuse adjacent over hypotenuse so
it's cosine so I could say cosine 45
degrees is equal to my horizontal
velocity over 10 or my horizontal
velocity is equal to 10 times the cosine
of 45 degrees I'm about to run out of
time so I'm not going to continue this
in the next video